first breaking tonight after only 11
days the secret service has now
officially ended their probe into the
cocaine scandal at the Biden White House
now according to their 11-day
investigation 11 long days uh well we'll
just never know who left a bag of
cocaine behind in a secure heavily
monitored area of the West Wing of the
White House it will forever be
apparently a mystery apparently no
fingerprints on the bag no DNA evidence
no surveillance footage no eyewitness
accounts no suspects at all whatsoever
although they do have a surveillance
coverage camera coverage of everybody
walking into the West Wing how about we
look at all those people and interview
every one of them first before we end an
investigation now we're talking about
the most heavily monitored and secured
building on the planet Earth and new
tonight we're learning that this was not
the first time illegal drugs were found
in the Biden White House it was the
third time the Secret Service just told
members of Congress that this was the
third time that an illegal substance was
discovered in Joe Biden's White House in
the West Wing so my question why are we
learning about these other two instances
right now at this point
and the two other occasions involve
marijuana no one was ever charged we
were never told why was that hidden from
the public now obvious question is the
Secret Service like the doj and the FBI
are they now part of covering for
someone at the Biden White House so are
they now willing to throw away their
reputation in order to protect Joe Biden
his administration for what would be a
massive Scandal let me ask this question
what if that white powdery substance
that people shove up their nose happen
to be Anthrax or what if it was cocaine
that was laced with fentanyl all which
is not uncommon with the Secret Service
I just brushed it off after a pathetic
11-day investigation and by the way what
if this was the Trump White House do you
really think Federal investigators would
drop the case after only 11 days anyone
here believe that
look they investigated the Russia hoax
for three years that case never should
have been opened according to Durham
they had no evidence at all whatsoever
and everything in the steel dossier uh
was false keep in mind this probe has
been unusual from the very start a lot
of confusion and this raises questions
you know seeping out of the the Press
first we're told that the the cocaine
was discovered in the library at the
White House residence then the West Wing
Lobby uh then it was near the situation
room now we're told it was actually
located in a locker near The West Wing
executive entrance where you have a
camera viewing everybody going in all
the while many speculated if the cocaine
belonged to one of the president's adult
children both of whom have struggled
with drugs now of course until recently
Hunter Biden was a notorious crackhead
look he's sleeping there with a cracked
pipe in his mouth
it's a great way to fall asleep anyway
obviously not with a penchant for losing
important things you know he lost his
laptop his Firearms his cell phones and
for so many Hunter seemed like a
plausible suspect but you weren't
allowed to say that out loud especially
since multiple White House officials
refused to unequivocally rule out
members of the Biden family you might
remember take a look
when asked if this was a family member
for Andrew Bates to say I cite the Hatch
Act which has to do with elections oh
bizarre Joe Biden's asked questions
about this he doesn't answer Kareem
Jean-Pierre asked about the family and
she derides the reporter I would have
gone to Trump and said they're saying
this is your family member he would have
said absolutely not I would have gone to
the podium and said I have zero reason
to believe this is anyone in the
president's family why she didn't do
that I do not know
even more suspicious Kareem Jean-Pierre
lied about the Biden's whereabouts on
the Friday before the weekend that the
cocaine was discovered despite her
denials both Joe and Hunter they were at
the White House until 6 30 on Friday
afternoon she said they weren't there on
Friday and of course tonight this is
about much more than a small bag of
cocaine it is about security at the
White House and a very real perception
that your federal government based on a
mountain of evidence that a Democrat VC
can pretty much do anything they want
including hard drugs inside the White
House or in some cases hire prostitutes
like Hunter skip out on paying taxes
commit felony gun crimes not file with
the federal laws in this country with
few of any consequences we saw that with
Hunter a slap on the wrist but if you
are a Republican or God forbid Trump is
your last name buckle up prepare to have
your world upended sideways in each way
in between Queen local state federal
officials all in search of any possible
crime that is the current state of your
so-called justice system in America and
with Democrats in charge it will only
get worse hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else